what I could do is play a Gambit every
game in the warm-up Arena
and then switch styles for the title
Arena
maybe people would enjoy that here it
goes
I Gambit every game
the blitz warm-up Arena
uh oh it's pentatonic
this is a strong player to maybe I'll go
for like a streaming or something
ah there's a Gambit here what's a Gambit
though
I think it's F5 foreign
[Music]
but I I remember seeing this somewhere
let me switch sounds
okay opponent really didn't accept the
candid though
so am I supposed to do Knight D4 takes
takes
Knight D5 takes looks interesting
also looks a little bit questionable
but still interesting Bishop B4 no
Bishop B4 hangs a piece
uh Knight F6 Bishop G5 this might
already be bad for me
I could
play Knight D6
I play C6 takes takes
this is so confusing actually
foreign
also like time wise this is Blitz chess
it can't take too much time
so I'm pinning the pawn
reminds me of like um
uh two knights Main Line there is a line
where like the pawn is pinned like this
foreign
[Music]
I wonder if I can get away with taking
it's questionable though
Rook B1 probably coming
wow E5
so if I take
I can take and play D6
what a weird position I'm up two Pawns
that's kind of annoying of King f8
and King f8
getting out the way
I'm still kind of pinned
Bishop E6
I'm scared White's gonna have tactics at
some point
your Rook here
I want to play rookie seven
I'm also threatening to take and take
puns he's a threat
okay everything up
she don't know what I'm doing
taking H5
F4 is also a move
hmm
foreign
oh wow good move
ah everything's pinned
very nice move
Dole I'm getting mated
no I'm just losing everything
oh man that was a rough game
a rough finish
ah I got beat by the Wayward Queen
attack what to do
but F5 I think is like um a playable
move
it's actually one of the best moves in
this position
[Music]
opponent was apparently prepared though
I have six
I just get completely outplayed
94 is a mistake
wow
so I didn't really stand the chance in
this game
are they just losing the whole game
I was up two pawns at one point
oh this game has already analyzed what
probably made one mistake
but it was always I was always winning
for Wyatt like
soon after the opening
what to do
okay good game
that was uh that was tough so the first
game was
F5 Gambit versus wayward
Queen attack
okay
let's berserk I'm gonna try and rebound
a little bit
of gambling against the pier it's maybe
this
I don't know if I can play a simple
gamut here or I'll try and Sack
something at some point
yeah let's just sock stuff on the king
side
if takes I probably don't take back I
probably played G5
okay so I've sacked upon I might win it
back
but I'm focusing on development
and Center
style of a true gamma tier
now black castles there might be some
opportunity to
do things on the queen side
it's take hitting the bishop
and black provoked me throwing back the
pawn
and now okay now I'm hitting the bishop
Bishop f8 runs into Knight F6
um can I
advance
yes now I'm gonna win upon
I took the bishop with Chuck hitting the
Rook
um you should probably defend
defend an attack
I'm below a minute but still plenty of
time
okay we'll trade
so I'm only down the pawn the one Pawn
I'm down is the one that I originally
gamuted
okay we'll transferred back hitting this
Pawn
if Rook eight I want to play B4
eventually but the rook's defended so
Paul's not actually pinned
they take
okay threatening the fork finding this
oh there's a funny mate King F5 King F3
and then Knight D4 mate
okay
there's also a funny Fork
no mercy
okay one game down
uh
what was that
uh H Pawn push versus Pierce
there's actually a cool tool that um
I was sent yesterday
that maybe I'll share after this stream
but it relates to the list I'm making
here
I'll share it after uh the tournament
actually
okay all dessert we'll play um let's
play some D4 Gambit
Dutch I can play stun they have six I
think this is called the bronstein
Gambit
delayed grob
opponent declines it
so it leads to at least to a funny
position not entirely sure what's
happening here
but I'm not down material
not sure if I want a castle
we're actually getting a more positional
game
hitting this Pawn
gaining space on the king side
uh maybe Rick
Rook C1 preparing C4 if Knight A5 I play
Knight E5
the A4
look at this move
and I just happier on D3
if maybe if I probably Bishop F1
oh
okay threatening F7 F6 might be played
uh nice move
yeah the bishop wants to be here
94 probably King E1
hey that might be a little bit worse
here
getting kicked around
it's not so bad though
um
I was more scared of taking earlier now
I'm winning a pawn
and the main thing I've gathered of this
game is my time
move
okay we'll go for the maneuver
I wanted to from earlier
so some idea Rook A4
um okay I want to play Knight C5
which would be a nice Outpost
it's taken this
okay six ideas
E4
E4 is really close to winning
maybe King D3 first
ooh
preventing Bishop B5 in the future
foreign
96 is a fork
Bishop A6 King D2
foreign
okay
I mean there's Bishop off one there
I should have plenty of time here
Queen H1 Checkmate okay
okay bronstein Gambit completed
back to tournament
onsteen Gambit
D4 io6 G4
thank you Zhao Hunton happy seven months
okay
uh staffer Gambit time
Stafford gamut time
I'm insisting
don't make me invent okay
sometimes white will play Bishop C4 and
then I have to invent something
but we have a staffer Gambit
transposition
going for this I'll go for each five
idea Knight G4
I should know the theory here
what was the theory
I know white is is better in the main
line
ooh
okay Bishop G4 was the better move I
think in this line I can play Queen E5
hitting H2
and white might already be in serious
trouble
not sure though G3
I mean not only threatening to take
upon's pinned
it's a good move
okay it's now threatening G5
that's still interesting
and this is a quintessential like
Stafford attack Bishop Knight each pawn
queen other Bishop
well it's a little bit clumped up
I didn't want to take an open e-file
it's sometimes a big source of counter
play for whites
so there might be an idea to take and
take
or take and create the battery
okay now I'm feeling pretty good because
the light squares are very weak and
white just traded off light squared
Bishop
there's almost a funny line where I
sacked the queen
now let's start with
start with this
yeah the King side's still not easy to
crack
might repeat
maybe still Queen H7
that's not easy for white to like find a
clear plan either
okay so I've created the battery
I mean I don't think this is a threat
because Bishop takes
oh well
and some idea Bishop D5
Maybe
yeah maybe I'll prepare F6
and time is leveling which is good
F6 now is too risky
and still getting kicked around
okay so Knight's pinned this Pawn is now
hanging
D4 might come
F6 is a purely intuitive
Queen F5 would force a queen chain
okay now this is looking really nice
oh no White's Queen oh no I'm getting
forts
okay
uh real quick analysis board
um is it winning after Queen E1
Queen E5 is much better
it's still tricky though we actually
played the top Engine line
oh HD3 here this is a move I wanted to
play takes
I can take on F2 uh okay
okay
um let's work again
okay it's Ortho snap time
oh what is this
uh
can I play a delayed nozzle loss
how do I play a delayed nozzle walls
wait now I'm just confused how do I
gather the pawn
okay let's just uh connect eight
or at least Connect Four
don't want to count my pawns before they
connect eight
okay that's my One goal of this game
the connect 8 Gambit
where you Gambit opening principles for
content
okay let's play this
it's close it is close oh that's
annoying move
I can't allow the trade apparently let's
play this hitting the pawn
all the pawns are getting traded no
matter what
okay I'm at The Rook
D5
okay
oh wow
okay so the knight's kind of pinned F5
is coming
I guess Knight F3 and castling
my C6 traps a knight unfortunately
that's okay I can
try and make do
castling first
wow look at this night
wow opponent gives back tonight
so I'll play B6
and The Rook wants to come in probably
to see seven
now he wants to come into E5
Pawn wants to promote
all my pieces have life goals
oh G4 queen wants to checkmate
and the g file wants to open
so material wise I'm somehow up a pawn
here
I have 24 seconds left
oh
uh let's play F5
I just want to open the files and
Checkmate the king
another idea to bring the Knight here
and then Queen here
I have to be aware of counter play
though
oh no we need three
how bad is this
maybe it's not so bad
preventing this and preparing this
wow
that was a really bad decision
draw
wow he drew
wow I was just gonna flag if uh
I mean King H7
or even after 97 King F7
okay
I lost a few reading points there but at
least I didn't lose
so that was Stafford
uh and or the game before was Stafford
um
attempted connect eight
still enjoying the most excellent
content okay the good work
I'm trying berserk again we'll play
um I'll wait before
I think Gambit here
I could play a reverse of walrus
which might go into Stafford
oh I'm getting this pong pong's not
taking it though
okay I'll play E5
sometimes you can't force opponents to
accept the Gambit
and now I want to gather The Exchange
wow
uh oh
I'm in trouble
[Music]
a little bit of trouble here
okay I'm getting my king safety
and upon
am I winning
no that just doesn't work
close to working
the bishop is hanging though
so I'm defending the Knight with a queen
Pawn battery threatening this
It's actually an interesting position
because Bishop D3 is coming
G4 doesn't quite trap the queen but it's
close
I think I just want to play Vision ah
what a move
by this hitting the Rook
What's Happening Here
I know it's happening
foreign
oh no
okay maybe it's okay
this is such a confusing position
it's probably just really bad for white
but I'm still surviving
Down The Exchange
good move
now I'm down a rook
down a little bit of time
yeah a good move
I'm getting needed regardless
that was uh
uh
uh the king Gambit
Abbott my king
that was rough
I know actually the middle game position
was interesting though
like there were chances for counter play
but something went terribly wrong
okay uh it's walrus time
so this is a walrus
which I've I've had this position before
it's very dubious but it's kind of
interesting
the pieces get some active development
only down the pond preventing castling
and G3 is a good move
at some point I might want to take and
4C takes
you uh further read
my castle
each
in this
idea of this and
yeah this looks like full compensation
here like can't Castle either way
and now there's major issues with the
queen
and King
I can play this move
discovered what do we call this
discovered skewer
hmm
foreign
night
no it's actually holding on here
I'm still trying to be aggressive
please amp us on
F2
okay threatening made in one
it's still not over
now it's over
okay
that was a walrus
oh the other one was reverse walrus
let me just call this
reverse walrus
foreign
game is a little bit risky
um let's try osullivan
oh this line oh this this is not a
Gambit but it's a funny mind
ah
two there's four Queens on the board by
move seven
let's make another queen
oh it's so much fun
I usually try and play this as white
it would be funny if white makes another
queen too
I have to be careful though
wait
how do I
how I do this I want to make another
queen
oh this this is tricky
Pullman has a lot more time than me too
like kind of berserked okay I'm winning
the bishop
I think
am I gonna have three queens on the
board
before I move 20.
I mean opponent can't stop me from
promoting
oh what a funny position
here and what is happening
no one knows actually
I think it's pretty clear What's
Happening Here
I'm about to have another queen
opponent deprived me of three queens
that was a funny game though that was
the only way to stop me from promoting
was resigning
okay
it was still it was still fun though
the engine will give a close equal after
um after both sides get the new Queen
actually I have a game on my YouTube
channel it's called
six Queens by move 16.
it's a game I played a while ago again
Sonia Ling
that was a fun one
it's just a fun line
okay let's play whatever this is
uh let's control the center
it's a new Gambit it's like a wing
Gambit against the nimsovich
okay
I'll stay with playing aggressively
um
I'm not sure if I've agreed feel for
this position
also moving just too slowly
I have the score for the knights
the A3 was important because otherwise
they're deep it should be for
I don't mind the position now
and there's clear plans Rook G1 F5
only trying to confuse me
really close to winning the Knight
and now I'm hitting the night
okay there's this idea
so rookie at F6 F6 is actually coming
pretty much regardless
C1 is off limits
hmm
Rook C2 Queen d8 checkmates
really close to mating
uh the best
thank you
okay I don't think uh black can stop
this
despite the time situation
this looks very very good
thank you Asian invasia
okay
does this have a name I'm curious
move to
the wheeler Gambit that's cool
okay the wheeler Gambit did I miss one
wheeler Gambit I think there is one
before that
ah the Queens yeah
uh Four Queens
opening
how could I forget
okay so nine games so far
up opponent blizzard King let's play
whatever this is called
what a funny opening already
let's play A Smith Warren now
uh I insist on the Smith Mora
it's somewhat questionable
uh-oh
okay I've definitely gambited something
hey but like I have the bishop hair
I want to buy each five
Target the knights and this first
hitting the pawn defending
H5 is coming soon
oh this Pawn's hanging then this Pawn
hangs
wow
King f8 Maybe
oh wait my Queen's hanging what
Queen C5
free thing
everything in life is free
what oh it's not free
to play this
ah this is really bad good move
okay I'm losing stuff
oh no my position
foreign
hey Eric
oh hey
oh sad it was a cool position too it was
such a cool opening
okay
what to do
thank you PDF
uh
walrus no what was that called 903 G5
okay what were some mainstream gamuts
people were suggesting
I'll play a hillbilly
not that moves means dream cabinets
opponent's not accepting
uh maybe I'll still continue with
hillbilly ideas
put the queen in
okay
and block did not take the pawn earlier
so
it's equal material
am I queen getting
a little bit stuck
the queen is going on a journey
okay I guess we'll trade Queens
so E6 is actually a clear weakness here
I guess E5 is coming
and there's other weaknesses
in the Box position as well like D6
if Rook d8 I play uh Play Bishop B6
okay 94 coming soon
let's hold on to the bishop
oh good move
[Music]
hey
it's Mr F chess
shout out to Muhammad Reza
who I saw recently in real life
if you're just joining
um a little bit long time so I kind of
have to focus
I appreciate the raid
uh like sack something
play this first
idea of Rook D1
yeah some nice bad reaction
I guess no I
from what I thought takes Knight B5 but
okay this is looking real real nice
Oops
why I did that
okay now the cleanest technique but
it's something
okay
oh was Mr fjazz also playing duck chess
oh we should have a duck chess match
but this is real chess for now
um if you're just joining I'm playing a
gamut every game
trying to have some fun games
that last game was E4 hillbilly
Billy vs Carroll Khan
let me go for Stafford never played this
opponent before
so 25th place oh this person's in second
place wow
I guess it makes sense so you don't want
the berserk back
they're trying to win the tournament
oh Stafford gamma declined
yeah we're following uh how you found
versus jubov
this is already like a pleasant position
for black
five
okay I'll take
can I get away with taking
yeah I wanted to win D4 but it wasn't so
clear
I'm still a pressure points
maybe next yeah
I mean there's Pawn takes but looks kind
of ugly
so I have to find F6
can I take on D4 anyway
wow okay I'm going for it I'm sacking a
piece
so Queen takes I win the queen if Pawn
takes I'm down at night
but I'm threatening this threading this
this is the main thing I was looking at
um
it might not be enough
but it might be
uh it might not be
takes
now we have to treat Queens
I want to play each five at some point
there might not be enough time
check
okay I can move
now this doesn't really work
or does it
I'm trying something
Jack
oh no
I think this would be seven
the problem is F4 just defends
everything
another problem is time
another problem my Nate's just trapped
yeah well played
okay not my proudest game
I was a staffer declined
I had nothing to do with making duck
chess
it's just a a thing I stumbled Upon A
few days ago
it's been fun
I'll be I'll be releasing another Duck
video probably after this stream
okay
yeah rating is taking a beating
ah let's play um
let's play enactments and how about
I haven't played nagmundson in a while
uh what is this sign
the scotch Gambit
new Scotch Gambit declined
which is probably a reasonable way of
playing
okay I'll gain space first
I guess I'm gathering the bee Pawn
there's a line never mind
my [ __ ] got four
graph take six takes there's like Queen
B3 anything F7 and B4
might be threatening Knight G5 here
I'm playing Ultra aggressively
it's knobs under a queen I was about to
play Queen E3
okay now Queen E3
D1
good move
yeah under a little bit of pressure here
threading this now
the problem is at any point that I can
maybe take except not not there
and black had to trade on e4 first
okay somehow this is working out
the night in defending
this now
uh needed this move
thank you to GM tranquilizer appreciate
the raid
you're just joining I have 22 seconds
left
trying to
convert this position
[Music]
oh it's close to working
in this move first
foreign
s
wow I was really close to flagging there
like one of those moves was not a
pre-move
okay
I was really close
okay final game approaching
thankfully there will be a small break
between
uh this tournament next tournament so
I'll have a little bit of time to cool
down I forgot to put on the Harley
monitor
let me uh let me activate this
where is it
here it is
oh yeah this will probably be the final
game
um I've already played this and this
let's play this
and now this okay you got it
Knight C6 I think they call this a Dark
Knight
oh wow what is this
okay some grab scandi English ready type
opening
it's like a double grab
the queen is so brave
I mean this maybe
play G4 H5
oh
very strange position
that's a good move
okay I have the E5 Square now
I'm down the pawn though
that's we've done two Pawns
but I have an active King
a very active King
don't hurt me
door I'm getting hurt
I'm a higher than White's Pawn shelter
oh my king and my time
okay I guess I can count it for the
tournament too
it's time to take a break that was that
was a warm-up tournament
got some fun Gambit sir what was that
last one
ready
um I think they call it the black
Mustang
grub
no it was Borg
the Borg is reverse grab and then white
played the grub
English
okay
I may have missed a few
of these at some point oh I wanted to
show this cool new tool built by
Traveler
it's called leeches YouTube timestamper
and basically what I could do
oh I don't even need this list I guess I
could modify it later but um
what I do is I take the first game of
this
so the first game I played
copy the URL
and then paste it into this site
and then generate chapters
and what this does
is it will make nice timestamps for the
Future YouTube video